بعد دقائق من الابتداء المباراه بين
المغرب وبلجيكا شاهدنا الكثير من الحشود
الشباب الذين يبدون الدخول لحضور المباراه
بالرغم انهم لا يحملون تذاكر لهذه
المباراه والذي حدث ان الفيفا قررت ان
تعبئ الملعب المقاعد الفارغه طبعا بدخول
هؤلاء الشباب والكثير منهم تدافعوا بشكل
سريع الى هذا الممر لكي يكونوا من الاوائل
الذين يدخلون الملعب ومرور مشاهده
المباراه ولو في همم الجزء الاخير من
المباراه ولكن كمان نشاهد يعني هناك ازحام
وهناك الكثير من هؤلاء الشباب ويوجد
الكثير من السيدات كذلك بين هؤلاء الشباب
الذين يحاولون الدخول ولكن همم الذي يحصل
ان الكثير منهم لم يحصل او طلبه الحصول
على تذكره خصوصا من الشباب المغاربه بدخول
حضور مباراه منتخبهم همم ولكن للاسف كانت
معظم همم او همم اكثر همم التذاكر قد بيعت
همم خارج او قبل المباراه همم
نرصد الان ما سيحدث يعني نشاهد هناك رجل
امن يقوم بادخال بعض الشباب الذين كانوا
في الصفوف الاوليه من الدخول عندما سمح
لهم بالدخول لمشاهده المباراه بالرغم من
انهم لا يحملون بطاقات او تذاكر لهذه
المباراه في كاس العالم هنا في قطر ليث
بساريا العربيه الدوحه من امام ملعب
الثمامه قطر